our mouth is uphold it does absolutely
nothing for the air coming into the
lungs it is no function whatsoever and I
would say that our ancestors only mouth
breeders in times of emergency our mouth
is for eating drinking for speaking and
our nose is for smattling and breathing
there's so much going on with this this
little thing on our face here you know
we should be using it more often too
often we forget about it it is a
tremendous and Powerful exercise it's a
little bit tricky but we have to bear
this in mind if we have a belief that
the more air we breathe into our body
the more oxygen that's going to be
delivered throughout the body that is
not true we should consider that nasal
breathing during running is like lifting
weights you're adding an extra load to
train the breathing muscles but also to
improve your breathing from a
biochemical dimension in other words
you're training your body to do more
with less so it's tougher at the start
but then it gets easier because the air
hunger diminishes now as you improve
breathing patterns and the ball score
increases to over 20 seconds it's a lot
more comfortable breathing in a lecture
than others so it's just a transition
however once we adapt it and bring it
into our way of life it's not just our
sleep improves our dental health will
improve
oh my goodness there he is how you doing
Patrick good how are you Evan I'm great
so uh I I was gonna tell the story but I
wanted to wait for you to join so we
have a mental friend uh my dentist Dr
Mandeep who uh told me I had to breathe
through my nose wow more that's great
advice though it is the unusual coming
from a dentist I'd love to see all
dentists saying that but uh it's great
advice I have a mouth guard from a
previous dentist I have I have tape that
I use every every night as I'm going to
sleep and it works and she told me I
need nasal strips so I got I got my
nasal strips here too that I put on
every night but her tweak was you need
to also work out with mouth tape on
like okay that sounds crazy so I started
it I did the the weights are fine but
when I started running
the first I did like a half hour run the
first few minutes was like 90 through my
nose and then I started cheating it was
like half it was like breathe in through
my nose and out through my mouth and
then by the end of the Run dude it's all
it's like I put it's all now I'm just
full-on cheating running you know with
mouth tape on and the mouth guard is
like how could this is not possible to
breathe just completely through your
nose through a cardio exercise and she
said it is you gotta talk to Patrick and
so I reached out and here we are and um
I hope you can fix my breathing man so
so what do you got maybe maybe tell us
quickly about you you know from my
audience and the YouTube audience who
watch the replay
um and then we can dive into how to
actually fix my breathing sure sure I
came across breathing about
23 24 years ago and it's been my
full-time occupation since it was a
great discovery for me I had a few of
the issues that you had I was tired of
waking up
um mouth breathing during sleep and I
had respiratory issues and it affects
the mind as well because you know if
sleep is poor and if your breathing is a
little bit faster and upper chest you're
more likely to be in in that increased
stress response so I just find Evan my
concentration going through high school
and University was very poor and I read
about it in a newspaper article and I
taped my mouth that closed and I use
those nasal dilators by the way because
my nose was bunged up but there are
exercises you can use to decongest a
nose and the second morning after using
it I woke up with the best night's sleep
I had in about eight or nine years and I
knew then there was something in it and
the other thing I kind of found was
interesting back at the time instead of
taking these four big breaths that
people talk about
I was doing the opposite I was thinking
really soft right there and a really
really slow gentle without under
breathing
to the point that I felt I wasn't
getting an affair and the temperature of
my hands increased I always had cold
hands and feet and of course through
your breathing you can influence your
blood circulation and oxygen delivery
and there's a lot more you can do it as
well so running is a good one though
it's a great start how do I improve my
bolt score maybe what is a bolt score
and then and then guide me through you
know live demo how my breathing sucks
and what I'm supposed to do to fix it
your bow score is the same it's a it's a
measurement of your comfortable breath
whole time and normally we have
individuals say sitting down with normal
breathing for about five minutes or so
and then they take a normal breath in
through their nose and out through their
nose they pinch their nose and hold
their breath and they time it in seconds
how long does it take until they feel
the first definite desire to breed or
the first involuntary movement of the
breathing muscles in other words it's
the length of time of a comfortable
breath toward time following an
exhalation now what does it give your
feedback of it gives you feedback of
your breathing patterns so there was an
interesting we've been using it for two
decades or so an interesting paper
published by Kyle Kiesel he's a
professor of physical therapy at
Evansville university in the United
States he got 51 individuals he looked
at their breathing from many different
dimensions but there's only three and he
concluded that the Bulls score the
Bradford time it should be greater than
25 seconds if it's greater than 25
seconds there is an 89 chance that your
breathing is functional so what does it
mean then if somebody has a bold score
of 10 11 12 13 14 15 seconds
it can indicate that breathing is a
little bit faster
it's upper chest it's harder and the
lower the ball score they'll often feel
that they're not getting enough air if
they feel their hunger so breathing is
effortful and how you breed during rest
is how you breed during physical
exercise so you're going for that run
and you have a sensation almost that
you're going blue well that's going to
be influenced by a few things it's
influenced by your boat score so if you
have a decent bow score it's easier to
sustain nasal breathing during running
it's influence by your Fitness to some
degree but it's also influenced by your
nasal Airway so if you have a nose like
mine which is pretty compromised we
we're already starting at a disadvantage
and that's why you could use the nasal
dilators
so basically they're based on the Cotton
maneuver when you go through your run
use a nasodilator but what I would say
is go easy the benefits of nose
breathing versus mouth breathing during
jogging and physical exercise there's no
comparison I'm out breathing we should
not be breathing through our mouths at
all our mouth is uphold it does
absolutely nothing for the air coming
into the lungs it's it is no function
whatsoever and I would say that our
ancestors only malpreaded in times of
emergency our mouth is for eating
drinking for speaking and our noses for
smelling and breathing there's so much
going on with this this little thing on
our face here you know we should be
using it more often too often we forget
about it okay so why is mouth breathing
so bad well if you breathe through your
mouth you typically engage the upper
chest so upper chest breathing is not
ideal because it impairs gas exchange so
nose breathing will increase the partial
pressure of oxygen in the blood by
nearly 10 percent that's known since
1988 when you continuously breathe
through your nose if you do physical
exercise which are my clothes carbon
dioxide is higher in the blood and by
practicing and continuing to do your
exercise with your mouth closed your
tolerance to carbon dioxide improves so
you we should consider that nasal
breathing during running is like lifting
weights you're adding an extra load to
train the breathing muscles but also to
improve your breathing from a
biochemical dimension in other words
you're training your body to do more
with less so it's tougher at the start
but then it gets easier because the air
hunger diminishes and it typically takes
about six to eight weeks for the air
hunger to diminish so don't worry about
that feeling that sensation of air
hunger as you go for your job which are
my closed that's telling you the carbon
dioxide is increased in the blood and as
carbon dioxide increases in the blood
the red blood cells are releasing more
oxygen to the working muscles so in
terms of getting more oxygen delivered
to the working muscles nose breathing is
where it's at
nose breathing also a better recruitment
of the diaphragm and to die from
breathing muscle isn't just for
respiration but it's there to provide
stabilization for the spine so there's a
relationship between functional
breathing and functional movements and
if breathing is off movement is off and
if movement is off we're more prone to
injury
nose breathing is protecting the Airways
so it's literally moistening it's
warming it's humidifying it's
conditioning that air as we're taking it
from the atmosphere into our lungs but
it's bringing it up to the correct
temperature moisture Etc and we also
harness at the gas called nasal nitric
oxide or nitric oxide that's coming from
the paranasal sinuses when we carry that
gas by breathing through our nose into
our lungs nitric oxide bronchodilates it
opens up the Airways it's antiviral
so in terms of you know also
redistributing blood throughout the
lungs so the human nose has about 30
functions and this was written back in
the 1970s by an ear nose and throat
doctor called Dr Morris Cottle and
there's also a connection between the
nose and the Brain via the olfactory
nerve so we have to consider that when
we do nose breathing memory and
attention improves
but also in terms of
in terms of nose breathing visual
spatial awareness increases so if people
are playing sports they're able to have
their attention one thing but they're
able to scan their environment I think
our nose was something that had to
protect us from predators back in the
day when we were hunting that the term
sniffing out danger I don't think it's
there by accident you know I think our
nose is is that that communication with
our nose to the brain we we select our
mates based on the communication of the
nose not from the mouth so I don't know
what mouth breeders do when they're
selecting their mates their partners and
so it's different with nose breathing
versus mild breathing I think this whole
time I'm just only breathing through my
nose now yes as you're talking just
fine keep my mouth closed uh does it
matter for the exhale or just an inhale
only thing
you know during physical exercise you
could start off with nose nose breathing
and that would be the best way to do it
but there is a time when physical
exercise gets a little bit intense you
could be breathing in through the nose
and after them out out through the mouth
is having to get rid of the gas carbon
dioxide which in turn is helping to
reduce air huh
that aspect of it would be fine now it
doesn't really be making sense still
breathing in through the nose and outro
them out and the reason being is when
you breathe out through them out during
rest the breath out is faster
and a faster exhalation is activating a
stress response
so it's the speed of our exhalation that
the body is telling the brain whether
the body is safe or whether the body is
under trash now when we breathe in
through the nose and when we breathe out
through the nose the nose is a smaller
entries an exit so it creates a
resistance to breathing to help slow
down breathing and that's very important
for the mind so it just doesn't I think
in India fair enough you know in very
hot temperatures people might have been
breathing into the nose and out through
them out to get rid of heat to bring
down their temperature but the downside
to that is that you're losing moisture
there's a 42 percent greater water loss
by breathing out to the mouth versus
your nose so we should be breathing in
and out through the nose you know if we
went into nature and we started looking
around at the animal kingdom you're not
going to find too many animals breathing
into it or nose and nature of them out
so why is the human animal doing it we
don't know got it so uh so my dentist
said that you trained her to breathe
better through the nose what what
exercises do you do is there something
we can do you live like how do you train
people to breathe better through their
nose well let's start opening the nose
first you know because if the nose of
Stuffy people typically have them out
open and people don't just have a stuffy
nose they have poor sleep so a stuffy
nose and poor sleep go hand in hand now
what I'd say is don't do this exercise
if you're pregnant if you have any
serious medical conditions and we can go
off we can start off easy anyway gently
bring you into it anytime the nose is
stuffy or if you have a head cold take a
normal breath in through your nose and
out through your nose and pinch your
nose and hold and just walk
10 pieces 15 pieces holding your bet
and then let go and breathe in through
your nose
so even 10 15 Paces it's quite easy you
know like this would be a breathing
exercise that would be immediable to
most people and if somebody has anxiety
or panic disorder to go a little bit
easier and you know there's something
else happening with that exercise that
as you're doing doing that breath hold
you're generating a slight feeling of
discomfort and the whole aspect is to
relax into the feeling of discomfort to
train your brain not to react to
discomfort so building up your
resilience but it's also increasing
blood flow to the brain so that exercise
will have to increase blood flow to the
brain now I'm only going to give simple
exercises just to kind of give people an
Insight so we'll do it again Evan you
have to do it about five times or so
okay now only do it until you feel a
moderate air hunger don't worry about
pushing it because normally go easy at
the start take a normal breath in
through your nose no we shouldn't really
hear it either
yeah exactly and we'll talk about that
in a little while because that's
interesting take a normal breath into a
normal silent breath entry you know as
an asylum breath I'll pinch for nose and
hold
and then let go
now many people at the end of it when
you need to let go and only hold it for
maybe 10 to 15 Paces starting off okay
so go easy on yourself because some
people here if they're prone to anxiety
they might find that the breath hold
brings up too much of a stress response
so we can keep it we can alter the
breath hold that it's suitable for us
and it is activating a stress response
so this wouldn't be relaxation and it's
thought that it's activation of the
stress response that the blood vessels
in the nerves which have expanded that
when you do that exercise you're helping
to constrict
the blood vessels in the nose and that's
how your breathing then is easier in and
out through the nose it's not just
opening up your nose but it also opens
up the lungs
so as we breathe in and breathe out and
hold our breath nitric oxide starts
pooling in the nasal Airway and then
when we let go we're carrying this
nitric oxide Laden air into our lungs
and nitric oxide has happened to open up
the Airways it's antiviral Etc so we'll
do it one more time and let's say go
easy enough and keep always about a
minute to rest in between each take a
normal breath entry you know as an actor
you know as a pinch your nose and holes
and just gently unfolding the breaths
so maybe about 10 pieces 15 paces
and select over to breathe in through
the nose
and get your breathing under control
so that's an exercise that has been
known since about 1923 that when you
hold your breath you can decongest your
nose
and the thing about the human nose is
that the more you breathe through it the
better it works and anybody with any
sort of agitation of the Mind nasal
breathing will improve sleep helps to
stimulate the vagus nerve assist with
slow breathing improving oxygen uptake
improving oxygen delivery better
recruitment of the diaphragm and better
calmness of the mind so mouth breathing
we should be thinking of it's a stressor
and so the jogging element is that
because I want to be able to run uh with
my with my nose you know wide open our
mouth closed or is that just for anybody
even if they don't want to go running
uh we just did this we can do just any
sort of physical movement
so okay I just did jogging on the spot
because
we're both standing so we could do it so
yeah got it but you could be you could
do any physical movement but they're
actually things at the movement it's not
just sit down on the couch and hold your
breath well you could once you're moving
your body as you're holding the breath
on the couch
okay okay
and then what and just keep increasing
the the length of how long we're doing
that
suppose and you know what Jewish there's
nothing extreme with this because it you
know I think we always have to tailor
breathing I always like to get people to
dip their toe into the water when it
comes to breathing breathing can be
fairly powerful and uh you know
experience tells you that with some
people you have to go easy and just
gently Build It Up over time so I always
like to see people just dip their toe
into the water start off easy and then
they can just gently increase it when
they're comfortable with it okay and why
not a full like you said I shouldn't
hear you breathing no deep breaths why
not a full big deep breath
see there's something very interesting
with this you know there's a belief in
the western world that the more air we
breathe the more oxygen that gets
delivered throughout the body and that's
that's false
initial facts it's it's entirely
incorrect you know when we breed light
if we think about healthy breathing
think about the people who are healthy
you won't hear their breathing it's
hardly detectable it's driven by the die
from its in and out through the nose and
then we think about the people who are
you know if they have various conditions
or they run well or you know very poor
Fitness levels notice how they breed
they breed a little bit Harder Faster
upper chest irregular breathing mouth
breathing so our breathing can often
give us signs of where that person is at
in terms of health and when we breathe
hard and fast we get rid of too much
carbon dioxide from the lungs and blood
and this causes blood vessels to
constrict so our blood circulation is
influenced by how hard and fast we breed
and if we breathe too much air it
impairs our blood circulation but it
doesn't just impair blood circulation it
reduces oxygen delivery throughout the
body so here's an exercise that we could
practice Evan if you're up for it very
simple let's go yeah
so one hand on your chest one hand just
well actually you know I'm going to have
you do it slightly different I'm going
to have you put your finger underneath
your nose like this
and you're using your finger as a
barometer of the amount of airflow
that's coming out of your nose onto your
finger
so you're taking a soft gentle breath in
through your nose
and a really relaxed and a slow and a
gentle breath out through your nose
and a very soft gentle breath entry of
the nose
and a really relaxed and slow gentle
breath out through the nose
now as you're breathing out through the
nose I would really like you to slow
down the speed of your breathing so that
you're breathing less air onto your
finger so can you breathe out so slowly
onto your finger to the point that you
feel hardly any air coming onto your
finger
and then an almost imperceptible breath
in so it's an imperceptible breath in
that you're softening and slowing down
the speed of air coming into your nose
to the point that you're hardly
breathing in on the air
and then you're having this really
relaxed and slow gentle breath out
so what I would like you to do is I
would like you to under Breed by about
30 percent or so breathe 30 less air
than what you were breathing before you
started and you you were doing it
correctly if you feel your hunger
yeah
air hunger will signify the carbon
dioxide is increased in the blood
and as carbon dioxide increases in the
blood
it stimulates the vagus nerve
notice the change there will be a change
very often but most people the change in
the amount of water is sliding them out
so the other thing about carbon dioxide
is that as it increases in the blood it
helps to improve blood circulation
people notice their hands are getting
warmer it increases oxygen and delivery
so this is a breed light exercise that
has so many benefits but it doesn't
really get that of all of the breathing
exercises I use 26 different breathing
exercises that is my well that are
another variation of it is my favorite
it is a tremendous and Powerful exercise
it's a little bit tricky but we have to
bear this in mind if we have a belief
that the more air we breathe into our
body the more oxygen that's going to be
delivered throughout the body
that is not true that's not true
so so when you when you called me Adam
saying hey you probably had some air
hunger I said yeah I had took a big
breath into my mouth
sometimes
yeah yeah
so so how do we it's so automatic it's
like I'm 42 years old this is like 43
years of breathing incorrectly how do we
start to unwind those natural habits
just doing it gently and what I would
say probably during the exercise when
you first started off as you were doing
it there the air hunger might have been
just a little bit too much okay but
where we want to get it is with practice
that we're just gently taking that soft
breath in and that really relaxes and
slow gentle breath out surfing and
reducing the volume of air that we
breathe into their lungs but just enough
that we feel an air hunger but we don't
feel stressed
so this is kind of not too little not
too much just right but it's it's that
practice it's that practice of it you
know it's a great exercise it's a great
anchor to the brain and it would also
increase now that is an exercise that
will increase oxygen delivery to the
brain and blood flow and it activates
the rest and digest response people feel
sleepy so we often have it for recovery
now during the exercise itself heart
rate variability will drop a little bit
but after the exercise heart rate
variability which is a measurement of
resilience or balance of the body and
mind that will increase so yeah great
little exercise
so I'm never really filling up my lungs
you want me to breathe on less air not
necessarily what we're looking to do is
to get a match between your metabolic
needs and your breathing volume okay so
if you want to fill your lungs full of
air well then exercise your body go for
a run and as you go for a run your
metabolic activity your metabolic need
is increasing and as a result then
you're breathing your ventilation is
increasing so so yeah it's just having
that much it's really kind of just
putting out the idea that you know if
you go into a studio and if the
instructor is telling you to take these
full big breaths what is the purpose of
that because that could be actually
hyperventilation and very likely it
could be and hyperventilation it's not
good for blood flow and oxygen delivery
but it's not good for the the idea that
it's putting out there so you know this
is just I would say to anybody listening
look at the bore effect Bohr
um as carbon dioxide increases in the
blood and blood pH drops the Affinity of
hemoglobin for oxygen reduces look at
the vagotropic effects of carbon dioxide
just papers by Dr Singh James nestor's
book has written plenty stuff you know
in terms of carbon dioxide I've got 10
books out there going back to 2002
talking about the same stuff so none of
it is new heaven but yet it seems to be
a secret that hasn't got out there and I
think you know when I was looking at
your profile and you described yourself
as an introvert that's an introverted
breathing technique it's not getting the
attention but it's quiet but
it's very powerful and the techniques to
get all of the attention are the
extraverted techniques because they're
seen they're visible they're in people's
face there's a whole thing around it but
always think about the introverts the
introvert is the one to watch for I like
the connection there Patrick that's
great so listen as I'm doing this as I'm
breathing in and breathing out through
my nose and trying to practice while
you're talking and I'm listening and I
find like every five reps or so I feel
like I don't have enough in my lungs and
I want to take a deeper breath is that
normal does that go away how do I handle
that it will depend on your boat score
if your bow score is low you'll very
often feel that you may not have enough
air for the first few days
but once you continue nasal breathing
I'm not I'm not saying with people with
breathing light it's not about breathing
light all of the time
it's having a normal inhalation and
having a normal exhalation but in and
out through the nose
now if you're breathing with a normal
inhalation and normal exhalation in and
out through your nose but if you feel
our hunger I would say to you continue
breathing that way because the air
hunger will diminish the air hunger just
signifies that carbon dioxide
sensitivity is a little bit strong and
as you continue to breathe in and out
through your nose butchering rest during
sleep and also during physical exercise
your body becomes more tolerant of the
gas carbon dioxide and when your body is
more tolerant of the gas carbon dioxide
your breathing is lighter because when
we take a breath it's not driven by
oxygen it's driven by carbon dioxide
so every breath that we are taking into
our body right now is not driven by
oxygen we have so much oxygen in the
human body our oxygen levels drop have
to drop by half before the lack of
oxygen stimulates our breathing so our
breathing our normal breathing is is
determined is influenced by carbon
dioxide carbon dioxide is the primary
driver to breed but some people are a
little bit more sensitive to the
accumulation of carbon dioxide than
others and those who were a little bit
more sensitive to the accumulation of
carbon dioxide their breathing is faster
and harder and as a result then they're
going to be more breathless during
physical exercise
harder breathing during sleep faster and
harder breathing during risk which in
turn affects the mind so by practicing
breathing light and also doing physical
exercise with the mouth closed getting
them out closed during sleep improving
the boat score the sensitivity to carbon
dioxide reduces breathing becomes
lighter slower and lower and it is
tremendous capabilities for the mind in
terms of concentration attention span
focus and ultimately happiness
so if I'm going to go my next run we'll
team up for half an hour am I trying to
breathe more slowly through it am I at
the start uh not doing as much of a run
like going at a slower Pace than usual
do I have to do anything in advance am I
doing some like five minutes of breath
work before I go for the ride what's
your counsel as I go for my next room
what I would say is bring nasal
breathing first into your everyday life
before the Run
spend about 10 minutes walking and
internet through your nose in other
words do a little bit of a warm-up
the warm-up isn't just in terms of you
know getting increasing body temperature
but it's also warm up for the Airways
and by breathing in the net through the
nose during the walk you're increasing
carbon dioxide in the blood so you're
getting better blood flow and oxygen
delivered to the working muscles now
during the warm-up you could do a few
small breath holes so as you're walking
breathe in and out through your nose
pinch your nose and hold your back maybe
hold your breath for 10 paces and this
is helping to start opening up the areas
Etc then as you go into your jog go easy
and you are better off breathing slower
so A reduced risk pressure rate but
Fuller breaths improves gas exchange it
improves what's called alveolar
ventilation the worst way to breathe is
Mount fast and shallow because so much
air gets wasted to Dead Space
so by breathing in the naturally the
nose let the nose sesh the limits of
your intensity in other words you should
be comfortable breathing in and out
through your nose during physical
exercise and nasal breathing is an extra
load onto your breathing during physical
exercise which will help to train the
diaphragm but it will also help to
reduce your chemo sensitivity to carbon
dioxide in other words make your
breathing lighter then so I just repeat
that very very quickly the first 10
minutes very very easy nose breathing
during walking breathing in and out and
you go do some reckles during that time
three to four bread tours maybe and then
go into a light Jog and only jog as fast
as you can sustain nasal breathing and
feel comfortable and you will be
surprised
with time
the more you practice nasal breathing
during exercise you're getting all of
the benefits including a better recovery
and your your ability to do physical
exercise will increase
all right I guess the homework today I'm
excited uh for tools so I've got I've
got the nasal strips that I put on every
night and the mouth tape that I I put on
every night is this something that is
that you recommend during the day my
dentist said do it while I'm doing the
exercise as well but is this like
obviously when I'm talking to you I'm
not going to have my mouth taped up but
should I have the nasal chip on like is
this to practice getting into until it
becomes our new habit is that what you
recommend people doing I I would only
recommend nasal dilators if people need
them many people they don't need them
um if somebody is feeling air hunger
when they breathe through the nose
during rest at the start they can be
doing the nose and blocking exercise and
if they feel the ear hunger is a little
bit too uncomfortable the nasal dilators
could be helpful but only if you need it
now if somebody has a compromised nasal
Airway it is beneficial to wear nasal
dilators during physical exercise
and it can be very beneficial during
sleep as well so especially at the start
like when I first switched from mouth to
nose breathing Evan I was similar I was
feeling I was not getting enough air
because I was a chronic mouth breeder
and that feeling that sensation goes you
know but breathing in and actually the
nose yeah it's a little bit of a
transition but it's a very very healthy
one we have to come back full circle
here our mouths do nothing for breathing
the first that I did this it was
terrible I felt like what if I need to
yawn what if I need to sneeze what if I
you know it's like all of the what ifs
and I had a terrible sleep but then
after that it's like oh it's not it's
not that bad it's not that bad and you
just get used to it so now where I find
it's harder to sleep if I don't have it
on my mouth uh so there's a there's a
lot there's a misconception maybe that
that's crazy you know you're gonna
suffocate yourself if you have mouth
tape on at night
but you know there is different mouth
tape we have a tape myotype and because
we've been taping we've been using tape
for 20 years so we're probably one of
the Pioneers with taping of the lips now
the Mayo tape surrounds them out and
pulls the lips together and the reason
being is because a lot of people can be
a little bit apprehensive you know in
terms of taping them out clothes so the
Mayo tape you don't have to cover the
lips so you can still have it I'm not
even sure I have one post I don't have
one close beside me but actually I do I
just will I show it to you just briefly
yeah so this here is is my o tape now
this is the beige color and it comes it
comes in a packet of 90 strips
and you simply just peel it away it's a
cotton elasticated tape now this is the
gentle one so it won't stick too well
with my beard but the blue one does so
now so that's that's sticking now now
the facial hair is not great with the
beige one and there's a tension here
that's pulling my lips together it's
pouting my lips
so not then if people you know if they
did feel the need to open their mouth or
sneeze or something you know or cough
they can cough then so and it's also for
teenagers you know because of course
with some people if they were to try
taping children's mouths we don't agree
with that what we do if the if the tape
is surrounding the map but over start
off during wakefulness first it's very
important that the person establishes
that they can breathe comfortably in and
out through the nose and uh I would
agree with you you know I think the
taping once you get them out closed
during sleep you start to notice your
Sleep Quality improving yeah
the tape matters
I mean I just have a 3M but the
stickiness matters I I might try yours
out the original 3M cake that I use is
way too sticky and when I pulled it off
I'm like losing skin it's bleeding like
this is not very thick skin uh like this
is I need to find no matter what I
should have called you earlier man it'd
be great
um but yeah I think there's a lot of a
lot of uh just fear because you're not
used to it you just think that's crazy
I'm gonna I'm gonna take my mouth closed
you know all the what ifs but I should
end up sleeping a lot better so the no
strips what my dentist said was she she
took her two fingers and like stretched
my face like this and said hey Tried
reading is it better like yeah it's
better it's like okay you should be
using uh either either the nose strip or
the or the like the thing that you put
in your nose that open up the nostrils
so I try for this one because it was
easier to get uh so it I mean it
obviously helps me but is that something
that during the day doesn't matter as
much if there's not a any strenuous
activity just more important during
workouts and sleeping
so the main thing happened is going to
be different person to person
if if a person feels quite uncomfortable
breathing through their nose during the
day
wearing a nasal dilator could be a help
and the nasal dilator is based on the
Cotton maneuver so by putting one finger
either side of your nose and just gently
prizing your nostrils
does it make it feel easier or does it
alleviate that sensation of air hunger
that you're feeling when you breathe in
that through your nose but many people
will be comfortable breathing in and out
through the nose and if they're not
comfortable is it because their nose is
congested well you can decongest your
nose by simply breathing in and out and
holding your breath and just popping up
and down holding your breath until you
feel a moderate air hunger then letting
go and breathing in through your nose do
it five or six times now as you improve
breathing patterns and the ball score
increases to over 20 seconds it's a lot
more comfortable breathing in a lecture
than others so it's just a transition
it's like everything else however once
we adapt it and bring it into our way of
life it's not just our sleep improves
our dental health will improve and even
from the point of view of dental hygiene
you know if we go into a dentist we'll
see posters likely talking about you
know use different toothpaste and brush
your teeth
don't eat sweets so children are told
don't be drinking frizzy drinks and all
that information that's out there but
what about breathing through the nose
because if that child Rideout is going
around with their mouth open their mouth
is drier bacteria is more rampant
because saliva saliva serves a purpose
it's helping to protect their teeth and
in terms of map readers they are more
prone to dental cavities gum disease bad
breath and chapped lips so even from a
dental health point of view nose
breathing is very important
and so you've been doing this for quite
some time what are the product Services
you know programs that you have for
people around this we have a huge swish
we have different classes for anxiety
for sleep for for asthma for sports
performance for mental focus for
corporates for and we've instructor
training we have a lot of a lot of
materials you know we've been around for
20 years we've 10 books published in 16
languages so you know you'd find it from
our websites and we have a new app as
well coming out in about two weeks it's
free
and the app will have about 130
different videos
and it pretty much contains a tailored
breathing daily plan so anybody that can
download the app for free they can put
in their details they can choose their
plan and it will give them breathing
exercises every day but reminders to
develop habits but more importantly a
video of the exercise and audio of the
exercise Pacers etc etc so we put in 12
months of work the reason we're putting
it out for free is we want to start
getting breathing out there into the
population you know it's it's I've seen
it like in fairness it has the you know
awareness has increased quite
significantly in 20 years but we're
still a long way to go in terms of
improving people's concentration and
improving people's resilience and stress
enhancing capabilities because Evan you
know how many of us have spent 12 and 16
years in formal education we haven't
been taught how to concentrate and we
haven't been taught how to deal with
stressful situations and I think
nowadays there's even greater challenges
because youngsters now are so exposed to
information technology and mobile phones
Etc and ultimately they are distraction
devices even though we're using them
here but they should be used to a limit
and I think there's I think there's a
real need you know to get breathing out
there so yeah our websites
oxygenadvantage.com we have Instagram we
have YouTube Etc so we're on all the
platforms pretty much
I love it well YouTube I will link that
up in the description below if you want
to go check that out and dive into
Patrick's world I'm looking forward to
the app I will definitely try that
myself uh Patrick thanks for your
education and the time today and I'm
gonna go for a run and let you know how
it goes
for the best of luck with us and you
know yourself
dip the toe into the water and go nice
and easy because you'll enjoy it and
you'll stick with it so that's what it's
all about Evan to see my one-on-one with
Wim Hoff the Iceman check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there remember deep breathing is
able
is able to change the biochemistry
inside deeper than ever thought possible